un placer y un honor a estar ahí estar
hoy con ustedes cuando me hablaron de
que si quería dar una plática ted yo ya
sabía que era test
me hablaron de esta de mi cama en una
película muy tranquilamente me dicen oye
armándonos quizás apoyar dando una
plática ted yo estaba con mi novia
colgué inmediatamente y le dije te marco
al rato voy a checar mi agenda
obviamente tengo una agenda y no tienes
nada que hacer hoy
y no tienes
una amiga
qué amiga no pues un amigo que quiere
dar una plática tep
mi hijo en serio y que le dijiste que le
iba a marcar al rato para ver para
checar mi agenda
tú no tienes agenda
me dijo hazlo sal de tu zona de confort
with dijo la palabra mágica
la palabra que no nos gusta ir salir de
su zona de confort
hace 17 años
el camión en el que viajaba junto con mi
padre y mis dos hermanos se volcó
hay un barranco y mi brazo queda
totalmente destrozado
debajo del camión
el único recuerdo que tengo de ese día
es ver a mi padre hincado
intentando sacarme con las manos
la cara tenía totalmente llena de sangre
al día siguiente desperté en el cuarto
de un hospital
[Música]
vi a mi familia a mis abuelos creo que
jamás he visto tanta familia unida y
todos estaban ahí
voltee y mi brazo había desaparecido
de la noche a la mañana yo ya no tenía
una extremidad de mi cuerpo
ese día no solo yo perdí algo lo perdido
en mis papás y lo pero ni los hermanos
lo perdió toda mi familia
mis padres tuvieron que vender muchas
cosas creo que la mayoría de sus cosas
para pagar
el hospital después las terapias que me
tocaban a hacer
en el 2007 empecé cuente con terapias en
la natación
a los pocos meses y estaban compitiendo
con los mejores nadadores estatales en
una competencia local
empecé a ganar mis dos medallas y en el
2009 viajé por primera vez fuera de la
ciudad representar a mi país al niño que
le habían dicho que tenía poder
que no era bueno que pobrecito como iba
a lograr algo ese niño si no tiene un
brazo grande mis primeras medallas en el
2012 12 tuve la oportunidad de
representar a mi país en el evento más
grande y más importante que pueda
imaginar o que puede aspirar un
deportista los juegos paralímpicos de
londres
quedé en el lugar número 12 nada mal
para un niño de apenas 16 años los más
jóvenes de la selección
estaba contento con ese lugar pero no
satisfecho sabía que yo podía lograr
mucho más fue una competencia de la que
no me preparé y pues fue un lugar
después de esa competencia un poco más
maduro me puse la meta de entrenar
cuatro años completos
cuatro años entrenando ocho horas
diarias dos veces al día en la mañana
antes de ir a la preparatoria y en la
tarde pues saliendo a la preparatoria
a los 2 años o sea en el 2014 yo estaba
hasta la maíz yo no quería saber nada
del agua ya no quiere entrenar estaba
cansado física y mentalmente así que
decidí hacer un cambio completamente en
mi vida
cambié de entrenador
[Música]
tengo muy presente que gracias a ese
cambio hoy estoy aquí
faltaban dos años para los juegos
paralímpicos
y estaba más motivado que nadie trabaje
más duro que nadie para llegar a esa
competencia en un mejor nivel
faltando un año hicimos las competencias
preparatorias y nuestro selectivo
clasificó el primer paso lo dije
clasificar es lo más importante ahí
sacan la selección que va a representar
al país
al siguiente día
de llegar a la villa paralímpica
estaba más nervioso que nunca no podía
dormir casi a pesar de que tenemos un
comedor extremadamente grande con todas
las cosas que se puedan imaginar
al día siguiente de la inauguración
me fui a mi cama a descansar no podía
dormir me acosté dormir un par de horas
y me levanté para el día
que entrene esos cuatro años
en la mañana de la semifinal
clasificando el quinto lugar del mundo
lo había logrado
clasificar a mi primera final
paralímpica solamente los ocho nadadores
más rápidos del mundo clasifican y
tienen el honor de representar a su país
en esa alberca
una con muchísima historia los
últimos juegos de michael phelps y yo
estaba con toda esa energía a punto de
aumentar me des alberca
salí de la semifinal
con los ojos llorosos
me fui a ver a mi entrenador y le dije
así y me metí al albergue rápido aflojar
para que no viera que estaba llorando
obviamente se dio cuenta
sal y habló conmigo
me recordó todo lo que habíamos
entrenado
un poco más tranquilo en la tarde ahora
sí venía lo bueno
la final había tres chinos
un francés adelante de mí los chinos no
sé que les dan de comer pero bush son
muy rápidos
en la tarde / oficialía mayor que es un
cuarto nos ponen como caballos de
carreras formados dicen nuestros nombres
no checan que llevemos nuestro traje de
baño nuestra gorringe sus muebles
sin tatuajes
me quedé sentado escuchando música
respirando y recordando todo lo que
había hecho para llegar a ese lugar a
ese lugar que nadie me regaló a ese
lugar que tuve que luchar cuatro años
para ganarme
dijeron mi nombre
en un estadio
unas
cien veces más grande que esto
lleno de los mejores deportistas del
mundo los mejores deportistas
paralímpicos del mundo estaban ahí en
las gradas pues estaban llenos de
brasileños de japoneses algunos
mexicanos y me van a ver nadar
salí me senté
y empezar a respirar empecé intentar
calmarme porque mi pulso estaba a
reventar
cuando dieron el primer silbatazo para
subir a sus carriles
cierra los ojos y se me vino a la mente
todo lo que había pasado para llegar a
ese lugar todas las críticas
todas las personas que me dijeron tú no
vas a poder llegar lejos porque no
tienes un brazo y no tienes la capacidad
de lograr muchas cosas sólo por eso
al parecer juzgaron mal esas personas
pero también se vivieron todos los
recuerdos bonitos de mi infancia mis
hermanos me entrenaron
para la carrilla que tenemos muchas fama
de ser guerrilleros ellos tomaron ese
papel de entrenarme nada me lastimaba
estaba en el banco de salida en sus
marcas salir lo más rápido posible
sabía que si no me despegaba del francés
iba a llegar en un lugar
toque regrese y pues el francés se me
fue
venía medio cuerpo a delante de mí yo en
la madre
yo ya no podía andar más rápido que eso
mis piernas estaban llenas de ácido
láctico me dolían y pues con un brazo
pues más difícil no
dije ok armando aquí deja todo cerré
toque voltea ver la pantalla quinto
lugar del mundo
el mejor resultado deportivo de mi
carrera deportiva tres chinos enfrente
de mí y un francés
a lo largo de mi carrera deportiva de 11
años largos y de mucha preparación de
ganado más de 180 medallas nacionales
internacionales el 90% de ellas son de
oro cinco de ellas son mundiales
y les quiero dar entender con esta
historia o para que me pare aquí para
hablar con ustedes
para decirles que solamente hay una
palabra que separan a los exitosos con
las personas normales
esa palabra es disciplina
disciplina para entrenar para comer lo
que debes comer
y disciplina para no hacer caso a los
comentarios que no funcionan que nos
hacen daño
nadie tiene permitido en esta vida decir
la otra persona no puedes no eres bueno
para esto o no eres bueno para aquello
en lo que quieras hacer la vida te va a
golpear y te va a golpear con lo más
fuerte que tenga
tú tienes la responsabilidad de caerte
quedarte ahí tirado que la vida te
aplaste
o sacar tu carácter eso es lo que nos va
a definir
saber qué tan preparados somos para los
golpes de la vida porque la vida nos va
a dar infinidad de golpes en esta en
esta vida de un día para otro yendo
tiene un brazo he crecido la mayoría de
mi vida sin un brazo mis padres me
enseñaron todo lo que sé mis hermanos me
enseñaron a aguantar vara
y pues estoy muy agradecido con eso el
año que viene tengo tres eventos
importantes
juegos panamericanos de perú mis
terceros juegos logrando ser máximo
medallista en la selección nacional
el mundial de malasia la primera vez que
voy a volar al continente asiático
representar a mi país y un nuevo reto
que me propuse un nuevo reto que estaba
entrenando más o menos un año que va a
ser el mundial de surf adaptado cuando
les dije a muchas personas que quería
surfear me decían nada sal que armando
cómo vas a surfear
cómo estás a parar la tabla te vas a
caer tras hogar pero pues esas personas
no sabía quién era
muchas gracias a todos por venir nos
vemos en tokio
[Aplausos]